[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]
ADDY: One of the
main things that I
can't live without any
more on OS X is like Divvy
And all it does, it just comes
up it is with weird grid thing.
And you can just say, for this
window that I'm currently in,
make it this size and sit
over here on the screen.
And like, on my desktop where
I've got a full keyboard,
I've got a number
pad, and I've got
like, each portion
of the number pad
just relates to a
bit of the screen.
And it's just
like, it's so good.
MATT: So Divvy is
pretty awesome.
I've used it in the past.
And if you like a visual
UI for configuring stuff,
it's pretty cool.
I use an alternative
called Spectacle.
ADDY: OK.
MATT: It's open source.
But it does something
very similar.
Basically, you can use
keyboard shortcuts,
like say, OK, well, I want
to resize all my windows
to be on the left or
the right and just
like splice my screen up.
You know, they're
both solid options.
ADDY: Matt, I didn't
know that one existed.
Sounds good.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]